let s sub K for K is equal to 1/2 all
the way to 100 denote the sum of the
infinite geometric series whose first
term is K minus 1 over K factorial and
the common ratio is 1 over K then the
value of 100 squared over 100 factorial
plus the sum from k equals 1 to 100 of
the absolute value of this thing over
your K squared minus 3k plus 1 times S
sub K is so this looks like a pretty
daunting thing but I guess a good place
to start would just to be just to be
find find a a simple way to express S
sub K so if we were to write S sub K S
sub K is equal to the first term is K
minus 1 over K factorial and then the
common ratio is 1 over K so it's going
to be 1 over K to the 0 plus 1 over K to
the 1 plus 1 over K squared it's just
going to keep keep going on forever it
is an infinite geometric series now
there is a very well-known formula for
the sum of an infinite geometric series
I enjoy the the proof of it so much that
we're going to do it again and I've done
it multiple times already but it's such
a simple proof that it's always good to
start from basic principles if you're
doing this under time pressure you could
just use the formula but if we say let's
just say some other sum let's call let's
call this thing let's call this thing
just s s is equal to 1 over K to the 0
plus 1 over K to the 1 plus 1 over K
squared all the way keep going on into
infinity now let's multiply 1 over K
times s 1 over K times s is just going
to be 1 over K times each of these terms
when I multiply 1 over K times this term
I'm going to get 1 over K to the first
power
when I multiply 1 over K times this term
I'm going to get 1 over K to the 2nd
power all the way on to infinity so if I
were to subtract this from that so if I
were to subtract that so this is
coefficient is 1 so it's 1 so we have 1
minus 1 over K times s I'm just
subtracting that would be equal to all
of this stuff - all of this stuff that's
going to cancel with that
going to cancel with that we're just
going to keep canceling and we're just
going to have this first term here which
is to the 0th power or 1 over K to the 0
power is going to be equal to 1 or that
this whole sum is going to be equal to 1
over 1 minus 1 over K and so we can
rewrite S sub K so we could rewrite S
sub K S sub K is equal to K minus 1 over
K over K factorial times let's before I
write it up here let's see if we can
simplify this if I want to simplify this
I can multiply the numerator in the
denominator by K if I do that I have K
on the numerator and then the
denominator becomes K minus 1 K minus 1
so this right here is K over K over K
minus 1 and these will cancel out and so
this will be equal to we have to be
careful when we cancel it out because
this kind of precluded well I'll talk
about that in a second so this will be
equal to K over K factorial and what's K
over K factorial
remember this is equal to K over K
factorial is K times K minus 1 times K
minus 2 all the way down to 1 so these
KS are going to cancel out so it's going
to be equal to 1 over K minus 1 times K
minus 2 times K minus 3 all the way down
to 1 which is the same thing as K minus
1 K minus 1 factorial now we want to
make sure that we get the right value
for S sub 1 and S sub 2 so let's just
get this so s S sub 1 what's that going
to be equal to and 0 factorial is always
a bit of a debate that people can have
but it becomes a little bit simpler when
you look at the original expression here
if you put K is equal to 1 here this
just becomes a 0 you lose that because
it cancelled later on and that's why I
was kind of warning to be careful but we
have 1 minus 1 that's clearly going to
be 0 regardless of whether you consider
0 factorial to be 1 or 0 this clearly
clearly going to be 0 over here so S sub
1 is going to be 0 times a bunch of
other stuff so S sub 1 is going to be 0
what's S sub 2 going to be
S sub two is going to be now we can just
use this it's one over two factorial
which is just going to be it's just
going to be equal to one so with that
out of the way let's think about this
sum over here let's think about this sum
we have the sum unless actually before I
write it it's from K equals one to a
hundred but let's just actually figure
out so when K equals one S sub 1 is zero
so just this doesn't even contribute it
to it when K is equal to 2 we have a 2
here we have a 2 here so let me just let
me just write well let me just solve it
this way since we already got the 2
there and then we could start from 3
when K is eat when when K is equal to 2
S sub 2 is equal to 1 and then we have 2
squared we have 2 squared so that's 4
minus 6 plus 1 so that's negative 1
times 1 which is negative 1 but then we
take the absolute value of it so the
value when when so the second term here
the first term is going to be 0 the
second term here is just going to be
positive 1 positive 1 so this sum over
here is going to be equal to 0 this is
when K is equal to 1 plus 1 this is when
K is equal to 2 plus and now we can
worry about the sum from k is equal to
3/2 on 100 notice it was k equals 100
but I did the first two terms there are
0 and a 1 so now we have to just worry
about 3 to 100 and let's rewrite this
expression inside the absolute value
sign so inside the absolute value sign
we have this thing over here times S sub
K S sub K is this over here it's K minus
1 factorial so you have that whole thing
being divided essentially by K minus 1
factorial K minus 1 factorial this is
the S sub K it's 1 over K minus 1
factorial I'm just putting in the
denominator and you have this thing you
have that thing in the numerator now my
first gut and see to see if I could
factor this is no easy way to factor
this
but my second gut instinct hopefully is
to see is if there's any way that I can
express this in terms of K minus ones or
K minus KS or anything like that so that
somehow will make an easy pattern
because my what tends to be the case
with these type of you know you have
this crazy sum clearly or not be going
to be able to do it by hand things are
going to cancel out normally you have
things like that maybe they oscillate
maybe you have stuff like you know one
plus two minus two plus three minus
three and so all of the middle terms
cancel out and you just have the first
term in the last term that tends to be
the case for things like this one
there's not some easy simplification
over here or some easy formula like an
infinite geometric sum so let's see if
we can do that one way we could express
this so let me write this over here
separately K squared minus three k plus
one we could write this as K squared
minus two K plus 1 minus K obviously
minus two K minus K is negative three K
and the reason why I do that is this
this becomes a perfect square this is K
minus one squared K minus 1 squared
minus K and this looks interesting
because it's now expressing it in terms
of simple terms especially when you're
dealing with factorials you like dealing
with K minus 1 s and K's and maybe it'll
simplify a little bit
so I'll write this expression here as K
minus 1 squared minus K and let's try to
simplify it let's try to simplify it
even more so this whole thing is going
to become or at least we're just dealing
with the sum part right now we're not
really dealing with 100 squared over 100
factorial just yet but this sum is going
to be 1 plus the sum from K is equal to
3 to 100 of the absolute value of we
have K minus 1 squared over K minus 1
factorial so I could let me just do it
separately here so I don't have to
rewrite the Sigma notation over and over
this expression right over here is the
exact same thing as K minus 1 squared
over K minus 1 factorial minus K over K
minus 1 factorial it's the exact same
thing
what's interesting about this term
remember K minus 1 factorial that's K
minus 1 times K - all right K - let me
write it this way K minus K minus 1
factorial is K minus 1 times K minus 2
all the way down to 1 that's what this
term is right over here so we have a K
minus 1 squared up here we have a K
minus 1 the denominator this will cancel
out with one of the K minus ones out
here so this simplifies to this first
term over here simplifies to K minus 1
in the numerator over we don't have K
minus 1 factorial anymore we a now minus
2 times K minus 3 all the way down so
now this is K minus 2 factorial and this
is still minus K over K minus 1
factorial and this looks interesting now
this looks pretty interesting it looks
like a pattern might emerge we're going
if whatever the K is you go in the
numerator down 1 on the numerator and
down 2 on the denominator for the
factorial and then you subtract it but
then for the next K it looks like you'll
have some cancel let's let's try it out
with some numbers so this is going to be
equal to so when K is equal to 3 when K
is equal to 3 this expression is going
to be the absolute value of 2 over 1
factorial 2 over 1 factorial minus 3
over 2 factorial minus 3 minus 3 over 2
factorial so that's when K is equal to 3
and to that we're going to add when K is
equal to 4 when K is equal to 4 we're
going to have 4 minus 1 is 3 over 2
factorial 3 over 2 factorial minus 4
over 3 factorial minus 4 over 3
factorial I could keep going let's do it
when K is equal to 5 when K is equal to
5 I have 4 over 3 factorial 4 over 3
factorial minus 5 over 4 factorial minus
5 over 4 factorial I think you see a
pattern we're going to keep doing this
all the way to what's the absolute last
term the absolute last term is K is
equal to 100
so we go all the way to K is equal to
100 at 100 you're going to have 99
you're going to have the absolute value
of 99 over 98 factorial minus 100 over
over 99 over 99 factorial now the
pattern you might and of course we have
this one out front we have this one out
front now what's this going to simplify
to you might see the pattern we're
subtracting a 3 over 2 factorial we're
adding a 3 over 2 factorial we're
subtracting a for my 4 over 3 factor
then we're adding it and you might say
wait what about the absolute values but
you're going to look over here when you
see this the second term the second term
these absolute value signs is always is
always going to be is always going to be
a smaller value than the first term and
that's because we have that's because we
have a larger value over here we only
have K minus 1 factorial n factorials
increase quite quickly we only have K
minus 1 factorial over here we only have
K minus 2 factorial over here so this is
always going to be less than this this
right here is three-halves
this right here is 2 this right here is
what is it 4 over 6 4 over 6 so this is
only 2/3 this is 1 and 1/2 so the second
term is always less than the first term
so this is going to just evaluate to be
the same thing without the absolute
value signs this is always going to be a
positive value positive value positive
value so you actually could ignore the
absolute value signs you could actually
ignore the absolute value signs and now
it becomes I think pretty pretty pretty
clear how the cancellation is going to
happen you can ignore the absolute value
signs and now we have a situation where
the second term from this one for K
equals 3 cancels with the first term
from K equals 4 those cancel then these
two cancel then this is going to cancel
with the one from K equals 6 is going to
keep happening
this is going to cancel with the second
term from K equals 99 and we're just
left with we're just left with the 1 out
front 1 plus this 2 over 1 factorial
which is just 2 and then we have minus
100 over 99 factorial
- 100 over 99 factorial and remember we
also had this whole time I didn't pay
attention to one hundred squared over
100 factorial but I can do it now but
what is 100 squared 100 squared is 100
times 100 over 100 factorial so that's
100 times 99 times 98 all the way down
to 1
these cancel out this is the same thing
as 100 over 99 factorial which we're
going to add to it so this is 100 over
99 factorial right over here so let's
add that we have 100 over 99 factorial
lucky for us that first term and this
last term cancel out and we are just
left with 1 plus 2 is equal to 3 so that
fairly daunting thing the main trick was
trying to see how to simplify this in a
way that may be a pattern ruin immersion
that's really the hard part of this
problem but we get this entire sum is
equal to 3